voilà c'est presque fini après trente
deux ans à la tête du jt le plus
populaire de france dans cinq minutes à
peu près le journal de la rédaction a
tout de suite il a décidé de tirer sa
révérence et de prendre sa retraite en
plein succès un journaliste qui depuis
près de 50 ans a fait son entrée dans le
coeur des français c'est demain 13h que
pour la toute dernière fois de sa
carrière jean pierre pernaut va
prononcer cette phrase
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à
l'occasion de ce tout dernier journal de
13 heures demain soir c'est 8 consacre
un documentaire exclusif sur la vie de
jean pierre pernaut en immersion dans
son quotidien entouré de sa femme
nathalie et de ses enfants
celui que vous avez accueilli chaque
midi chez vous vous ouvre enfin les
portes de son intimité alors jean-pierre
pernaut va-t-il vous manqué nathalie ma
chérie d'amour hors caisse caennais
orelsan a mis les paillettes comme toi
mais tu es toujours très belle ma chérie
bon bah jean pierre ça y est c'est
demain oui tu sais que je suis le jure
je pense que demain dès hier il va faire
un énorme records d'audience voilà elle
est déjà très avant-hier plus de 48%
il va faire un dix ans et dix mois la
vérité comment tu te sens pas avant
demain
ben moi je suis entre l'armée sourire
alors qu'avant j'avais la grande gueule
on disait ah oui il faut qu'il se repose
il faut qu'ils soient avec moi et là je
vois tellement le public mais c'est
désemparé serez des pleurs et des pleurs
et même jean pierre et on a l'impression
qu'on qui sort d'un endroit qui découvre
sa peau popularité parce qu'il est
tellement surpris de tous ces messages
d'amour
et il se dit mais ce que j'ai bien fait
parce que c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
c'est tellement difficile si on a besoin
de rappeler à bezons pure et européen et
je pense qu'il s'en veut un petit peu à
cause de ça et donc j'essaye un peu de
leur assurer pas il regrette ou pas
c'est pas qui regrette parce que ils
regrettent pas pour lui regrette plus
pour les gens est une légende
voilà ça lui fait très très mal au coeur
pour le voit le témoignage des gens de
ce qui se passe n'a été ouverte et ribes
les enfants si long que des messages moi
j'ai que des messages y reçoit des
milliers de cadeaux à tf1 même là devant
chez vous il ya des gens qui m'ont
ramené des cadeaux pour jean-pierre
c'est un amour mais un conditionnel
c'est très très très touchant ils le
méritent maujean pire que tu sais comme
comme je lai mais j'ai toujours été avec
lui
puis depuis le début est-ce que tu seras
avec lui pour son dernier jt je fais pas
dire en même temps je très embêté parce
que je dois partir pour miss france et
des masses et la course pour moi donc si
c'est la course c'est qu on reste devant
avec frites je sais pas peut-être pas
faire times
je ne sais pas peut-être un truc qui va
y avoir un prix alors jean-pierre on a
la chance de l'avoir avec nous par skype
jean pierre qui est un mec que j'admire
beaucoup et qui adore jean pierre tu as
vu tous jean pierre je suis très heureux
de voir ce soir tu sais jean pire un
jour il ya etienne mougeotte
je rêvais d'avenir sur tf1 et il m'avait
dit j'ai est un rendez vous avec lui
j'étais vraiment stagiaires et m'avait
dit
l'exemple à suivre c'est jean pierre
pernaut regarde le regard de jean pierre
pernaut quand il regarde la caméra et tu
réussiras et c'est vrai que non mais je
te jure que c'est vrai c'est vraiment ce
qui m'avait dit et je trouve que c'est
vrai que tu as tu captes les gens demain
c'est ta dernière
qemu - jean-pierre j'appréhende
énormément cette dernière journée est le
regard là il est un peu fatigué ce soir
je suis complètement épuisé par cette
semaine on a fait plein de surprises à
l'antenne et où c'est vrai natale il
disait j'ai je mesurais pas à quel point
les gens émettant ce jour mais les
mamans mais c'est toi j'en perds c'est
toi qu'ils aient mais aussi dans le
journal aussi et bien sûr mais c'est
vrai que c est ce que tu te dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un moment on
a vraiment besoin de repères toi tu es
un énorme repère pour les français tu
nous tue les rassure tous les jours à
13h est ce que tu crois pas que ça va
faire un immense vide pour pour les gens
n'ont pas ce que je vais être bien
remplacé par marie sophie lacarrau c'est
sûr qu'il est une héroïne génial j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler avec elsa
depuis deux mois à tf1 elle a regardé
comment on travaillait elle a fait le
taux correspondant région elle est
pétillante elle est vraiment top donc je
vais j'ai parfaitement confiance en elle
leur père écoutez il faut bien partir un
jour moi mon repère à moi c'était aussi
trois en un jour il est parti bon on est
tous on est
parti à un moment ou un autre on part de
la télé personne n'est irremplaçable
et puis je m'en vais pas vraiment
puisque je fais là j pb tv vient de la
mettre en ligne
d'ailleurs c'est ma nouvelle plate forme
amériques où il y aura encore des petits
coups de gueule mais on est bien en
jambes en l'air
est-ce que vous avez préparé vous avez
préparé de un discours de fin demain
avec nathalie baye je sais qu'il est
très pressé ça fait plus de dix jours
il est tous les soirs je dis mais qu'est
ce que tu fais votre couche était
fatigué non il faut que je fasse mon mon
nom mon discours est alors une fois il
écrit à la main après hop je vois et
jettent à la poubelle après étape sur
l'ordinateur et ça aurait fait mais non
mais c'est trop long c'est beaucoup trop
long de lancer c'est c'est pas touchant
non c'est pas possible
et se prend la tête et ce point at-elle
jeudi mais heureux post va te coucher je
dis mais c'est pas possible donc il se
coucha dès 1h du matin alors qu'il est
crevé il a des dizaines dizaine de
réunions en ce moment des photos des
autographes
il n'arrête pas et elle a tout à l'invs
il va se coucher tôt après t'inquiète
pas demain demain à 18 heures il écoute
jean pierre rives avec l'éveil vanille
c'est pas bien j'en perds ça y est tu as
fini ta famille tu vas encore peaufiner
ce soir et demain matin c'est pas fini
parce que j'ai encore mes 15 papier à la
poubelle ce soit à d'accord je veux
simplement dire au revoir merci les gens
que voulez vous que je dise je leur dis
à bientôt sur lci le samedi à partir de
9 janvier
je leur dis à bientôt sur la jbb terrain
dans des magazines
bon peut-être des éditions ça fait sept
mille chemises que je te l'avais je te
passe
bon ça c'est beau ça c'est beau jean
pierre est ce que tu penses que je ne
regrette pas du tout contrairement à ce
que disait nathalie je ne regrette pas
une décision qu'on a pris vraiment avec
nathalie tous les deux cet été et je ne
regrette pas du tout j'en perds est ce
que tu penses que tu vas réussir à
contenir ses larmes demain parce qu'il a
une grosse émotion c'est sûr ça je n'en
sais rien je suis assez émotif cette
semaine comme une grève ou sans faire
tous les jours me réserver quelques
surprises chez beaucoup de mal à vous
quand et demain je peux je sais pas du
tout je me laisse aller
je me sais je sais pas ce qui se passe
du tout dans ce journal c'est qu'un
magazine sûrement à 14h15 qui racontent
pas acariés avec michel izard de ma
soirée le magazine sur ces huit
spéciales jean pierre
nady quand même avec des inédits et des
musiques ception rien attendent une
greffe at on dit oui grâce à guillaume
genton demain des images de ouf
vraiment je vous dis de 2 jean-pierre de
nathalie c'est vraiment on a même les
images s'excuse de son mariage allait
passer mais vu un valoir c'est vouloir
c'est du jamais jamais vous regardez les
images exclusives du mariage de jean
pierre pernaut et nathalie ça vraiment
c'est que pour ses 8 ce sera demain soir
à 21h sur ses vitres yard
[Applaudissements]
aux premières loges de cette union
françoise la maman de jean pierre
disparu depuis jean pierre et nathalie
mon bonheur je suis très fier d'avoir
matane et comme elle s'y attelle pétange
et abordage j'étais gravement malade je
peux pas mourir tant que jean-pierre
échelle alors n'a évidemment je suis
coincé parce que maintenant je crois
qu'il est plus seul mais je voudrais
[Musique]
voilà maman de jean pierre vous êtes des
murs anatolien oui oui parce que ya
beaucoup d'émotions soir plein d'émotion
son départ de demain
ces belles images pour demain grâce à
toi guillaume merci je sais que jean
pierre c'était son son mentor sa mère et
c'est très dur pour lui aussi je le
remercie de d'avoir accepté d'avoir
donné les images et surtout on a voulu
donner si les images pour romain si son
public pour lui faire un cadeau aussi à
son public parce que non mais je suis
voyage plaire mais a tellement enfin
bref
mais c'est tellement eu besoin pour mon
chéri et c'est vrai de voir sa mère elle
disait toujours je veux qu'il soit marié
je veux qu'il soit bien après je peux
mourir et revoir ces images là c'est
c'est beau et c'est vrai qu'elle avait
envie de continuer à vivre après parce
qu'elle voulait voir les enfants et elle
a vécu jusqu'à 102 ans donc c'était
magnifique et elle avait la pêche comme
jean-pierre et ça a été son mentor pour
jean-pierre comme son frère aussi qu'ils
étaient dans le truc et qui on a perdu
il a perdu son frère il ya trois ans
d'un cancer aussi du foie mais voilà on
a donné ces images pour faire un cadeau
merci à ces 8 merci à guillaume ces
images
bravo à guillaume parce que le devant le
documentaire sur jean pierre pernaut sur
ces 8es où il dit des images exclusives
ça va être poli je pense ça va être un
carton d'audience
moi je voi millions je pense s'arrête un
carton et c'est normal parce que
jean-pierre demain on va tous se
regarder ce documentaire we you bon les
gars vous allez découvrir toute la
famille pernaut qui est exceptionnel
parce que jean-pierre on sait qu'il est
exceptionnel nathalie elle y est pour
beaucoup pour le sud dans le succès de
jean pierre pendant que j'aimais aussi
elle est pour beaucoup dans sa longévité
vous allez découvrir ses enfants aussi
qui sont exceptionnelles et des hommes
loups qui est un peu grande gueule comme
sa maman et tom qui a beaucoup de talent
qui est plus discret mais qui est déjà
passionné de formule 1 qui fait la f4
notamment donc ça va très fort jean
pierre est ce que est ce que tu penses
que tu vas réussir à dormir ce soir
oui vraiment à ça je suis certain gluant
ce que je dis je je je suis en train de
jeu je vais dormir parce que je suis
complètement crevé mais j'appréhende
quand même la conjointe nathalie
l'émotion de matadi fille je sais pour
quelle sera la mienne demain mais moi je
vais suivre les surprises la rédaction
ça va être un journal jusqu'à 14h à
quelle heure elle levait keller alors
levé comme tous les matins depuis 7000
jours à 6h10 le matin 7h 15 je pars de
la maison 7h30 7h45 bureau conférence de
rédaction normal je pense qu'ils vont
faire une deuxième parce que pour la
partie surprise au courant de rien et
puis après un petit journal de 15
minutes sur l'actualité au début et je
dirais pour la dernière fois mesdames et
messieurs bonjour et à la fin je ne
dirais pas ça lui à lundi non je pense
que je donnerai la main à marie sophie
lacarrau pour qu'elle prenne la main
avant que je parte et chérie qu'est ce
que tu vas me dire demain matin avant de
partir au revoir chez rien n'arrête pas
de me dire ah il me reste un jour à il
me reste deux jours à elle a deux
matches à dire c'est mon dernier show
les faits sont des comptes non il ya de
l'émotion bien évidemment parce que 33
ans de toute sa vie d'un journal qui a
révolutionné la télé il ya longtemps
quand on a amené les régions asseoir et
parler des vrais gens ça ne s'opposait
pas à la télé maintenant c'est devenu un
peu plus habituel mais je me suis
bagarré pendant cette 7000 journaux
toujours on pense au lendemain et jamais
en france on a une carrière
mais là où j'arrête ce rythme quotidien
pour prendre un rythme différent
toujours dans le groupe c est ce un jeu
comme toi cyril je reste dans le groupe
à tf1 change juste des tâches exactement
jean-pierre en tout cas je voulais dire
un petit mot personnel je vais te dire
vraiment merci parce que tu as toujours
été un amour avec moi voilà même quand
j'étais eux je débuté et voilà c'est la
marque des grands voilà deux temps de la
main aussi à ceux qui démarrent et a été
un amour je voulais te le dire voilà on
s'était rencontré plein de feu edouard
les éditions moment forcément moi j'en
ai fait aussi mais l'ancien était
formidable
merci jean pierre je t'aime fort et
demain je te regarderai et jean-pierre
je te le dis tu va énormément me manquer
nous aussi vraiment nous aussi tu m'as
butera ouais je te regarde et je vais te
regarder aussi être regardées sur régime
et tv et sur elle si je te regarder
c'est sûr et certain jpp tv là quand on
est confiné cela va être extraordinaire
c'est des milliers de reportages à
revoir tranquillement dans un fauteuil
on voit tout le patrimoine de notre pays
c'est génial la taille est ce que tu as
un truc à lui dire avant demain même
voilà d'ici et ça qu'est ce qu'est story
comme conseil à lui donner avant demain
pour un petit jaune comme dimanche 7 à 8
on était très très touché aussi et j'ai
tiré c'est un petit jeune c'est très
rare envers le petit jeune parce qu'on
peut pas dire le nom de la nation
pendant les vacances
et là j'y tiens mais je verrai années
après son petit jeune donc partir
dimanche erik satie va bien dormir
nathalie vous allez dormir vous pensez
ce soir oui car oui oui vous allez vous
arrêter je m'endors toujours tard de
toute façon vous allez vous réveiller
avec lui demain
oui souvent je suis réveillée tôt les
enfants ils sont contents la décision du
papa mais je joue il se laisse vivre il
y laisse pas ses ébats très bien y voit
la vraie en tout cas je vais vous dire
merci nathalie merci jean pierre je
t'aime fort est vraiment demain je sais
que même moi je vais verser une larme en
voyant ta dernière je te le dis je
t'embrasse fort mon jean pierre merci
mon jean pierre faure marange et
champéry merci ma famille que l'avoir
avec nous nathalie bernat mouls format
série